- [Voiceover] Lets get some
practice estimating lengths.
So they tell us this line is one inch.
So that distance right
over there is one inch.
About how long is a toy car?
Well, this is one of those
lines that they just did
so that's one inch, but let's just see
how many of those we need
to go the whole length of the car.
So if I were to draw another one
that's about to that,
and I'm estimating, it's not exact,
that would be two inches.
That's one inch, that's two inches.
Then that would be three inches.
And then that would be four inches.
So it looks like the car
is about four inches.
Let's do another one of these
estimating length problems.
So I have a picture of two sunflowers
right over here, and they tell us that
this first sunflower
is 40 centimeters tall.
About how long is this
second sunflower going to be?
Lets think about it.
If this entire distance,
if this entire height is 40 centimeters.
And this sunflower, if
you look at its height,
I'll draw a dotted line here.
It looks like it's about half of
the height of the taller sunflower.
So what is half of 40 going to be?
Well, 40 is four tens.
Half of four tens is going to be two tens.
So this looks like it's
about 20 centimeters,
let me write it this way,
this looks like it's about 20 centimeters.
Another way to think about it is
if this whole thing is 40
centimeters then half would be 20,
then this would be 10 centimeters.
Let me write this, this
would be 10 centimeters.
This would be 20 centimeters.
Then this would be 30 centimeters.
Then this would be 40 centimeters.
So we already saw that the
sunflower is 40 centimeters tall.
And then this one would be half of that.
It would be 20 centimeters tall.